رغم الصغار اعمارهم لا تعرف حياتهم
الاستقرار حتى باتت المخيمات سكن ووطن
اطفال نزوح السوري في منطقه الباب شماليه
البلاد تقطعت بهما السبل بعد هروبهم من
النزاع المسلح وصولا لمستقبل ضبابين برفقه
اسرهم خوفا من عمليه عسكريه تركيه محتمله
شمال سوريا
[موسيقى]
تركيا وا
يقفون في وضعيه استعداد في مناطق تل رفعت
وعين العرب ومنبج شمالي سوريا
[موسيقى]
كذا مره باكثر من مرحله وعشنا حالات
النزوح الصعبه بالشتاء وهلا احنا نازحينه
قريبين على الرفعه
بنتمنى تكون عمليه رجعنا لبيوتنا يا اما
يتعمل له اتفاق بين بعضهم ويخلونا قاعدين
في المخيم اللي نحن فيه
نقطه قريبه على خط الجبهه
البقاء في المخيمات اصبح امنا وامنيات
العوده الى الوطن تظل حلما للنازحين
السوريين الشماليه البلاد لكن امالهم تبقى
اسيره قيام المخيمات في ظل استمرار
التهديدات العسكريه وتصعيدها بين اطراف
النزاع السوري
علي السمان العربيه